bonjour diane montrose mon jour et
bonjour aux auditrices et auditeurs de
martinique 1ère vous êtes la présidente
du comité martiniquais de soutien
françois fillion encore de nouvelles
révélations sur votre favori pour la
présidentielle à diane montrose pénélope
lilian l'épousé aurait touché près de 2
millions d'euros toutes ces révélations
notamment aujourd'hui avec le canard
enchaîné toutes ces réalisations vous
ébranle tel bien écoutez vous savez nous
au comité de soutien de françois fillon
nous essayons de faire la distinction
entre ce qui est de l'information et ce
qui relève du bruit médiatique et du
tapage médiatique
il ya vraiment un certain nombre de
questions que nous nous posons françois
fillon ses 40 ans de vie politique
voilà un homme qui a été député depuis
81 mer en 83 qui a été ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche qui a été offert tôt son cv
président avant de l'en qui aujourd'hui
mais qui a été promis l'été sur six
points et je vous dirais que c'est 40
ans n'a fait apolitique sans aucun
incident aujourd'hui à trois mois de
l'élection présidentielle
eh bien il ya un certain nombre de
révélations qui sont faites donc alors
qu'ils avaient éclos écoutez nous il y a
aujourd'hui une enquête une enquête
préalable et nous avons pris la décision
de faire confiance à cette enquête
notre candidat lui même avait demandé à
être entendu rapidement
c'est ce qu'il a fait aujourd'hui un
pardon du cac prend douvres
il a demandé simplement être entendu et
à pouvoir dire lui ce qu'il avait comme
élément mais hier c'était cinq cent
mille aujourd'hui c'est 900 milles on a
entendu que c'était fictifs on a entendu
qu'elle n'avait pas de badge je veux
signaler simplement qu'il ya aujourd'hui
des assistants parlementaires de nos
parlementaires ultramarins que ça soit
en guadeloupe en guyane en martinique ou
à la réunion qui ont un assistant
parlementaire ici
et puis un autre qui est situé à paris
l'assistant parlementaire si bien
souvent eh bien il n'a pas forcément
l'occasion d'aller à l'assemblée
nationale et n'a pas de badge donc vous
avez un léger comme une station fasciné
ordre moral que ni affaiblir gmt il y a
aujourd'hui une enquête et nous avons
nous le comité décidé aujourd'hui ben
d'attendre le résultat de cette enquête
je rappelle points sans qui viendra
ouverte entre avez vous le temps de
celle enquête qui décidera si oui ou non
le temps judiciaire et pas celui non le
temps judiciaire
mais je pense qu'on peut vraiment
s'interroger sur le fait que pendant 40
ans il n'y ait aucun bruit et que trois
mois avant l'élection présidentielle
et bien aujourd'hui il y à des
révélations qui serait faite
alors nous avons décidé effectivement de
faire confiance à cette enquête
parlementaire pour qu'elle dise ou pas
si les faits sont avérés ou non
et là il y aura un juge s'il enquête est
concluante pour décider de la suite mais
pour l'instant ce matin n'y a pas
d'affaires il ya du bruit
ce matin ce matin au sein même de la
famille des républicains
on évoque déjà un plan b plusieurs noms
circulent et parmi ces noms il y à celui
de françois baroin est inconnue pour
avoir été ancien ministre des autres
maires illégalement aux avis bertrand
vous quelque part en tant qu'individu
diamant kroes vous n'y avez jamais pensé
vous regardez moi je suis je suis parti
je vous le savez très certainement il y
a eu un rassemblement à la villette
ce dimanche organisé par françois fillon
j'ai participé à ce rassemblement parce
que nous avions une réunion préalable
avec l'ensemble des présidents de
comités de soutien pour remettre nos
travaux et puis il y avait ce
rassemblement à la villette
j'ai vu quinze mille personnes j'ai vu
plus de 15000 personnes
j'ai vu des gens déterminés de 60 films
français willy à 67 millions de français
bas il y avait quinze mille personnes à
ce rassemblement
eh bien je n'ai pas vu à ce
rassemblement des personnes en proie aux
doutes dont je pense aujourd'hui vous
étiez dans un
le jeu rêvé pour cela non mais je crois
que vous savez très bien vu qu'ils
avaient souffert bien dimanche
cette boule puante comme vous dites et a
déjà sorti et j'ai vu des gens
déterminés motivé en tout cas je vais
vous dire une chose si il s'agit
aujourd'hui de connaître de connaître ma
motivation bien je crois que lorsque
nous avons connu cinq ans de gauche
s'il ya une chose dont nous sommes
certains c'est que nous sommes vaccinés
de la gauche vacciner parce que nous
sommes vaccinés du fait qu'il y ait plus
d'un million de chômeurs de plus que
quand nicolas sarkozy a quitté son
gouvernement
vacciner parce que nous savons
aujourd'hui qu'il y a plus de misère
plus de chômage
vacciner parce que nous savons qu'un
gouvernement de gauche qui nous avait
promis du pouvoir d'achat et que ce que
nous avons eu en retour et les
martiniquais le savent ce que nous avons
eu un retour tout cela 0 des hommes
entation d'impôt à ne plus en finir
vous avez d'autres tout cela devienne
montreuse mais lorsque cette personne
françois fillion qui se présente comme
étant le support optique on relève
légèrement le tapis on voit de la
poussière qui date de plusieurs années
selon les révélations du canard enchaîné
ça fait pas d ordre tout cela écoutez
tout ça n'ajoute pas du disque riaa
c'est la classe politique
c'est la vraie question à se poser
pourquoi ce désordre à trois mois je
rappelle encore qui a 40 ans de vie
politique sans aucun incident françois
fillon a quand même été premier ministre
pendant cinq ans donc il était dans un
poste exposé et il n'y a pas eu de des
autres ministre aux finances ont de fait
on nous parle d'un ministre des finances
et selon lui on nous parle de faits qui
datent aujourd'hui d'avant et donc nous
attendons simplement sereinement les
résultats de l' enquête
alors vous étiez à la villette vous
l'avait dit pour des réunions de travail
que le candidat pour faire entendre la
voix de la martinique sur quelles
thématiques exactement et est ce que
françois fillon vous écoutez vu ce
contexte ce bois politiques médiatiques
comme vous dites bien écoutez nous avons
une mission celle de représenter notre
département celle de représenter notre
territoire et nous l'assumons
nous avons été faire entendre la voix de
la marque
nick et c'est une demande qu'est ce
qu'elle vit c'est une demande de
françois fillon dont je veux bien croire
que s'il nous le demande
c'est bien parce qu'aujourd'hui il est
attentif à cette voie eh bien nous a
joints aux antilles fin nous avons été
lui dire nous avons été lui dire un
certain nombre de choses nous avons été
alertés françois fillon sur la situation
de nos retraités par exemple en
martinique
alors c'est vrai qu'à la villette il a
effectivement dit que les pensions de
retraite seront revalorisées
mais nous l'avons alerter sur une chose
nous avons aujourd'hui des retraités de
plus de 75 ans ça n'est qu'en 94 que les
cotisations obligatoires pour les
entrepreneurs et les artisans ont été
instaurées en martinique ça n'est qu'en
96 que le smig lui a été aligné sur le
plan national
donc nous avons des retraités en
martinique qui font appel au fonds
national de solidarité fns
mais par contre nous lui avons dit une
chose la solidarité il ne s'agit pas
d'un prêt bancaire
vous avez aujourd'hui des retraités qui
renonce à ce fonds national pourquoi
parce qu'il y a une garantie qui est
pris sur leurs biens immobiliers
et souvent quand ces retraités viennent
à partir eh bien ce sont les héritiers
aujourd'hui qu'ils doivent se soient
remboursés ou le bien est confisqué et
l'autre ça soit flux audio curbans juste
à écouter nous avons avant le paon nous
allons nous avons remis notre copie
il a bien dit à la villette il y aura
des ajustements qui seront fait des
propositions qui seront faites et
tiendra compte de tous les travaux que
nous avons remis nous avons
effectivement rendu notre copie et nous
leur avons dit également que la culture
aujourd'hui en martinique
nos artistes locaux martiniquais sont
aujourd'hui bien souvent notre vitrine
touristique
nous sommes bien contents de voir la
compagnie créole zouk machine kassav qui
se produisent en chine en métropole mais
ça n'est pas possible aujourd'hui de le
faire ça n'est pas possible parce que
pour ces artistes locaux ça induit un
certain nombre de coups que les artistes
nationaux n'ont pas notamment les
transports
eh bien oui peuvent femmes en outre une
pétition qui sauf le rhône le busage
faune et le billet d'avion et bien nous
avons a demandé de plafonner nous avons
demandé qu'une ligne budgétaire puisse
être prise en compte pour les
déplacements de nos artistes locaux
aujourd'hui qui sans notre vitrine
touristique que nous avons demandé aussi
monsieur viol ton lorsqu'aujourd'hui on
est une destination martinique qui a une
grande richesse culturelle que ces
problèmes de réglementation concernant
les salles de spectacle le bruit soit
prise en compte et assoupli nous avons
demandé tout un certain nombre de choses
pour notre population martiniquaise
c'est sûr que françois fillon a fait un
axe prioritaire aujourd'hui de
l'éducation c'est très bien mais
aujourd'hui nous avons des parents des
milliers de parents qui ont des enfants
disent dyspraxiques dyslexiques
dysorthographiques eh bien vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui des parents on a tranché
à ne pas soigner leurs enfants parce
qu'ils ne sont pas reconnus comme un
handicap ne peuvent pas payer
l'ergothérapeute la psychologue et
cetera qui ne sont pas prises en charge
et rembourser que ça lui a dit qu'elle
sera la méthode de travail dans tous ces
secteurs que vous avez cités la culture
les seniors la jeunesse la santé comment
ça va se passer il y à un monsieur ou
madame secteurs cités nous avons
travaillé en bonne intelligence et nous
avons réuni autour de nous des personnes
qui sont experts dans le domaine nous
avons rendu une première que pile et je
les ai je l'ait rendue au nom du comité
de l'ensemble du comité de soutien de
françois fillon ce samedi nous
continuerons à travailler avec d'autres
professionnels de la place parce que la
qualité première d'un comité c'est de
savoir aujourd'hui être à l'écouté des
attentes et c'est ce que ce travail là
que nous faisons très bien il nous reste
une minute à peine dix ans montre aux
législatives on doit parler de vous on a
parlé de vous dans le centre
qu'est ce qui va se passer est ce que
miguel laventure va se décider de va
décider d'annoncer sa candidature
bientôt est ce que vous serez la
suppléante
mais à écouter vous voyez bien que nous
avons entamé un travail et si miguel
laventure aujourd'hui me sollicite pour
poursuivre ce travail parce que nous
portons avant tout la parole des
martiniquaises et les martiniquais dont
je serai à ses côtés pour porter
effectivement tous les éléments qui la
transition touchée de même dans une
aventure pour faire c'est avant tout une
décision personnelle je les ai rappelés
souvent vous m'avez demandé vous même si
moi j'étais candidate et je vous
dit que non parce qu'il s'agit d'une
décision personnelle
aujourd'hui il s'agit de porter la
parole de la martinique
il faut de la disponibilité il faut de
l'engagement et je crois que il
appartient monsieur laventure d'annoncer
sa candidature
merci des montres aux rappelle que vous
êtes président du comité de soutien à
françois fillon et que vous gardez la
foi concernant votre favori pour la
prochaine présidentielle merci et bonne
journée
merci
[Musique]